[Music]
foreign
Kardashian and Travis Barker are fully
embracing spooky season with an
over-the-top Halloween and party
[Music]
we're just you know living our best
lives and yeah to celebrate the premiere
of the latest installment of the horror
classic the barkers threw their own Mike
Myers themed bash and to No Surprise the
couple went all out
foreign
[Music]
trav's guests got hungry they offered
these not so appetizing options
[Music]
Court Sister Kim also joined the
festivities and couldn't help but show
off the decor herself
[Music]
yeah inside was pretty spooky but once
you got to the backyard it was a scene
straight out of a movie
[Music]
and it wouldn't be a Halloween themed
party without Mike Myers himself
oh my God thank you
okay so Kim and Court were there but
where was Chloe well she hosted a more
kid-friendly bash for the Kardashians
little ones her daughter true and her
cousin's Chicago dream and reign
[Music]
Coco rides alongside the clip memories
to last a lifetime for the kiddos it's a
beautiful thing
[Music]